- Sorry for having 43 tardies.
(laughing)
(pop music)
- I have certain teachers that are cool,
and they'll be like, "Well,
do you need help with this?"
And they'll like, hold you after class
and help you out with stuff.
Well others, they don't care.
They're just, "Okay, I'm here to teach,
"get paid, and leave."
- Something I hate about teachers
is that sometimes they
give too much homework.
Or they expect a lot but they don't really
give a good lesson.
(pop music)
- On average, how much did
teachers spend out of pocket
in 2016 on supplies for
the classroom and students?
- I mean, like, in elementary school,
you use like, crayons and markers.
- In high school, it's basically
all given to you, I think.
- 260. We usually bought the supplies, so.
- I'd say like the middle, 480.
- Yeah, 480.
- D, 480.
- D.
(bell dinging)
- No way.
- No.
- I thought that the school
gave them everything.
- I have a specific
teacher who, she gets there
at 6:00 in the morning for
help sessions until 8:00,
and then after school she
stays there until 6:00,
so it's like an extra
two hours she's there
before and after school.
She's not getting paid for it, either,
but she's just there to
make sure us students
are succeeding in her class.
As of 2014, over what percent
of public school teachers
in the US work second
jobs outside of school?
I know they're not paid a lot.
- C?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so 30%.
- So C, 30%.
- I think 20%.
- A, 20%.
- Yeah.
(bell dinging)
- That's still a lot, though.
- [Man] Would you guys become teachers?
- Yes.
- No.
You? (laughing)
- Yeah.
Almost what percentage of
teachers quit within five years
of starting their teaching career?
- My teachers from elementary school,
they were like one and done, so --
- Oh really?
- ... they would do a year,
and then they would leave.
- Maybe, C, 20%?
- Yeah. C, 20%.
- C, 20%.
(bell dinging)
- Wow.
That's a lot.
- Maybe the students are mean to them,
or give 'em a hard time.
- What percent of teachers are affected
by high stress levels on the job?
- C?
- Yes, C, 93%.
- I think it's C, 93%.
Because I'm learning that it's
very stressful and expensive.
(bell dinging)
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that makes sense.
- It makes me realize
how much teachers put in,
and sometimes they don't
receive it from the students.
- All you hear is like,
"Oh, I hate school.
"I don't wanna do my
homework, blah blah blah."
And like, teachers, maybe
some of them it's like
their dream job to teach,
and to like work in education
and stuff, so it's kind
of sad that students
can be rude sometimes.
Like, we should just, you
know, wake up and be happy
that we're -- you know.
- Instead of sleeping in
class, and disrespecting. So.
(gentle music)